I've talked about this on the podcast before but I have found this bug. This
was one of the first bugs that I ever, one of the first criticals I ever
submitted was a password reset token that was being generated by MD5 of the
user's email plus the current UNIX timestamp and I just guessed that shit
dude I guess I looked at that I did I guess all right I've had a thought while I was sitting on the toilet
great thank you thank you for starting the episode that way that's lovely so you know I was just
thinking like the bathroom definitely one of the most like what's the word I'm looking for looked
under a microscope like scrutinized scrutinized yeah most scrutinized part of the house you know
because you're just sitting there you're just you're just looking at oh there's like this tiles
missing grout yeah this wall you know there's a place for perfection in the house it's it's the
bathroom I think just for perfectionism true yeah anyways I know it's just I just that was the thought
of my head well thank you for starting this uh this podcast on information security and hacking uh out
with an analysis of what parts of the house are most scrutinized listen I'm just saying with our
backgrounds we could very easily do at least one whole episode about construction dude we absolutely
could we absolutely could that that's gonna have to be a critical thinkers exclusive I think episode of
me and you just yapping about real estate and uh construction renovation and all that all right man
we don't we don't have time to play today there is an absolute onslaught of awesome um research that got
published in the news for this week so um let's hit the ground running with that and of course we have
to start with our man Soroush of course yeah there I think there was some thread too that he's like man I've
got this like thing that I need to write up and like I just don't really want to do it
and then it was like a comment under something and then that comment like ratioed and blew up it was
like Soroush write it up please please write it up and I think this is the result of that so way to go
Soroush for actually getting uh the blog posted I know how difficult that is to stay on top of all that
stuff um absolutely yeah we've all been there we have we all have been there um it and okay so you've
got the next one so I'll go ahead and take this one um this one is a blog by Soroush and it is a
MongoDB NoSQL injection sort of technique um that he's releasing and essentially it's a describing a
scenario where you have a NoSQL injection into a collection which is like a table um in NoSQL
uh that is not really I appreciate you you translating this for us normies because even I I'm not like a
uh like a MongoDB aficionado like that I used I've used it maybe like two or three times in the last 10 years
like from a development perspective and I rarely ever hack on it so it's just one of those things that
you know having it in it's an edge case you know technology and and um I I did actually use MongoDB for my uh
recon system as my core database which was like interesting really not the right choice uh and I discussed that
um I will say every time I've used it I have I have somewhat regretted it like no SQL is is one of
those things that um it's really good for certain things I I would say I think like you're doing O of
one type stuff where you know the key then it's really quick for that like for storing documents
with like where you're not trying to really filter where SQL and like my SQL and like um you know that
relational data type of yeah yeah relational right like those are much better for like
querying select star from blank where X is Y and Z you know like that that type of querying is so much
better in a relational database than it is in a no SQL database would you say that relational
beta databases are better at relationships they also have that advantage right like there is that
whole implicit thing with like linked like foreign keys and all that kind of stuff that I don't I
think that exists at all in um in no SQL and that does like it's not necessary right like you can
build those relationships out yourself like you can store the same value in two fields or whatever but
again it like it has to go through every single document because it's not stored in that way so um yeah
it's definitely it's definitely a different a different approach and and it definitely was not the
right choice for me from a was that the same reason why you regret yeah well yeah there because at the
end of the day you're you're um when you're doing like mass guilt recon you're gonna be doing a ton of
rights and and not a lot of reads right you're just gonna be writing writing writing writing writing
constantly right um because you're gonna be updating all these rows every second you know um and and so
that was one of the things it's just Mongo doesn't scale super despite MongoDB being web scale uh it it
it doesn't it doesn't do a bunch of rights like that um super well uh in my experience and and there's lots of
other stuff we discussed it on the episode with Sean um uh Sean Yeo uh from asset note I hope I'm pronouncing his name
I don't know I wonder if people know what we're talking about when you say MongoDB is web scale we've
definitely talked about it on the podcast before but I think we actually talked it up talked about
it in the Sean Yeo episode did we I believe we did I think so I'm gonna put a link I'm copying it right
now I'm putting a link here's the video it's in the description yeah it will actually be in the
description so go check that out um or maybe just like put the graphic up on the screen dude it's like
I opened up a little card in in the in the doc and I just see that that character's face and it
just makes me laugh so much um okay Joel let me explain the freaking write-up okay um so anyway
I know it's playing in the background okay I didn't conclude so I'm sorry so Soroush uh mentions this
this way to deal with um no SQL injection um and essentially the the scenario is you're in have a no
SQL injection in a public collection so let's say for example a products collection or something like
that I think was the one he used in the in the write-up um how can you pivot this to affect other
collections when the collection is like sort of statically defined and um the way that he did this is he uses
this this whole feature of um MongoDB called aggregates and aggregates are ways to process these multiple
documents and uh run like various computations on them get them into a specific format filter them
that sort of thing there's two ways to do this you can use aggregate pipelines or you can use single
purpose methods in MongoDB um and uh single purpose method methods are pretty single purpose and not very
useful for this uh aggregate pipelines are are kind of the way to go and essentially what that allows you
to do is use a bunch of different functionality to um perform what would be the equivalent of like a a
union of sorts um okay with other collections uh uh in the database um i'm scrolling through this blog as
well and it looks like there also is like an actual union thing that you can do as well is that that's
separate from this or no no that's the same thing okay yeah so so um there's multiple i i don't actually
know the technical term for these uh they are essentially um dollar sign operations i i don't
know the technical term for them but i'm going to call them functions for for lack of a better um term
here but there's dollar sign lookup dollar sign union with dollar sign replace with and dollar sign
merge and those are the ones he highlights in the um write-up which essentially allow you to do
various uh operations within that aggregate pipeline and that pipeline is is a an array of various uh
operations that you want to perform on uh that the data the given data set so for example if you use um
dollar sign lookup it'll allow you to look up a an object in a different collection and attach that
to a specific field in the object that you're you're querying and you can combine that with limit so
that you only get one object back so you can query things very specifically um okay so really really
quick so i did a little google search here so the aggregation thing basically just takes a list of
operations that it's expecting to do in order okay yeah and so they're called aggregation operations and
there's a variety of them like match group um you know what was it look up um et cetera union with
yeah all those okay that's right i i knew i had the name in there somewhere aggregate operations that's
the one and um and so essentially the whole concept here the takeaway if you didn't listen to all that
rambling and joel and i's back and forth is that if you have a no sql i um a no sql injection then you
should absolutely be looking for uh ways to even if the the collection is limited you should be looking
for ways to use these aggregate pipelines um to be able to reach into other collections and pull data
out um and he includes a really helpful section in the blog post called how to identify if it's an
aggregate in black box testing so essentially if your no sql injection includes the ability to have
aggregates and essentially what he mentions here is that you should always look for anything that has
like dollar sign match or dollar sign lookup in it or that sort of thing um in built into the
application because that sort of indicates the use of these aggregate functionality and i've absolutely
seen these before in applications so i definitely missed something here um so be on the lookout for
those and then also be on the lookout for an array that seems to be providing some sort of filtering
because um this would be pretty much where you would define an aggregate pipeline um so if an api
request is taking in like a json array and there's some various um defining of fields that are being
pulled back or like operations aggregate operations like like joe mentioned then that's kind of the
indicator of like okay maybe i've got an aggregate um and no sql injection that supports aggregates here
yeah and it's one of those things that now that you know it you like like you said like you're
thinking back and you're like oh i've definitely seen some like dollar sign weird stuff in those
requests like i probably missed some stuff um make sure this is in your word list too right so that
you can you know either hit some errors maybe you can you know um as an exercise to the to the listener
go ahead and figure out some sort of query or some sort of parameter combination that will trigger an
error with these aggregate um you know calls so that you can put that in your word list and you'll get
a hit on your your fuzzes uh when you're going through and you'll know okay i need to poke at that
further that's probably you know a no sql injection yeah that's a great point maybe there's some end
points that sort of aren't using this function down in the front end but may have it in the back end
and by fuzzing for parameters inside the json body or yeah that sort of thing you might like maybe an
operation that doesn't exist or something i don't know yeah i know that that no sql is pretty json heavy
so i imagine you'll find this mostly in a json environment not to say that you won't find it outside of
that but um you know this is probably something that you're going to be brute forcing for in a in
a json uh environment although i'm thinking about all those all those like those grown bugs like the
the the show and tells type stuff where it's going to be some no sql injection through like a url form
encoded yeah that nobody was anticipating like yeah man yeah i always hesitate to even say stuff like that
on the pod sometimes because it's like okay clearly this is true because of the way that things work
but also there's going to be some caveat and i don't know maybe i shouldn't even say it but no
at the end of the day it's better for us to do sort of but generally speaking yeah hunting yeah yeah
yeah all right what's this next one we got here okay so this is a really cool blog post um
that uh i don't know what the researcher's name is other than stule stule 123 um did they did they
link any socials uh not that i saw but i'll try to hunt it down oh they did actually uh d schmid schmidt
schmidt s-c-h-m-i-d-t even not i'm sorry uh d schmidt 0 8 1 5 um has like 75 followers make that 76
because i just i just followed them nice um anyways so they did a really cool um blog post about a one
click account takeover in a very large chat app in south korea called cacao chat um so
if anybody's ever been to korea or um knows anybody in korea or friends in korea or anything
like that you definitely know about this app cacao is like massive in korea they're like one of the
largest sort of like technology companies i'd say but they're definitely more than just technology they
are in a lot of sectors i think one thing that was really interesting when i went to korea was
two things one like the emphasis of um local companies and local businesses so like google
maps barely works in korea but cacao maps made by the same company uh works great right and so um
you know most of the cars that people drive south korean uh manufacturers hyundai kia that kind of stuff
you don't see that to the same level at all in the us like people aren't like exclusively driving
american cars we drive tons of import cars so you see toyotas and nissans everywhere um so it's uh
it's very interesting the emphasis that i noticed in korea on like i've been waiting for my moment to
now derail you good sir since you derailed me during the no sql okay okay i i got kind of nerd sniped by
this because this is this is i pulled the joel moment here okay so i i was reading about this and i
didn't actually get but like uh you know a little bit into the blog so i'm gonna rely on you to
explain uh most of everything that happened here but i got like two seconds into it and it was like
oh kakao talk the biggest uh app you know in korea and i was like wait a second isn't lion korean
because i lived in japan and everyone in japan uses line like like it seems like it's also pretty
big over there yeah and and so i was like oh wait okay let me let me suss this out and it actually
looks like lion is actually gaining popularity in in korea now um but kakao talk is by far the the
leader there yeah uh which is which is pretty cool like i have kakao talk on my phone because i have
a friend who lives in korea oh really wow that's that's pretty rad yeah and same same for line you
know i use that for all my japanese friends um yeah but it made me also sort of think like as far as
like all these different countries go they all have their all in one app right line does payments
cacao talk does payments you said maps you know there's the all-in-one app for that country right
um china has like what is it like wechat or something like that yeah and so the us doesn't
have one of those and i think europe kind of does like wechat or something or what is it um what's up
what's that yeah primarily whatsapp so i i think it's it's mostly a cultural thing um a cultural thing
combined with um uh probably a lot of like smaller factors like you know economic factors and stuff
but in the us you see primarily people either text yeah right it's either text or it's imessage
and then if it's not it's one of the apps that the rest of the world also uses telegram signal
whatsapp or maybe one of the more niche ones there are a couple like messenger messenger
right like facebook messenger so like line like you'll almost never see somebody in the us using
it unless they're talking to somebody in asia right um so it's it's kind of it's kind of interesting that
the us never like really adopted like a single chat app but i think that's primarily because imessage is
very very popular here and one of the things that was pushed at least in in my memory is that imessage
works over data so it doesn't take international charges or anything like that it works over wi-fi
so if you're on wi-fi or you have you know internet connectivity it's not using like your sms like
you know you used to pay per message and all that kind of stuff and yeah right so um i think that was
a big reason why people were using whatsapp in other countries was so that they could chat you know
cross-country without international texting fees and all that kind of stuff especially with sms
yeah and with the us just being as huge as it is i think the issue isn't there quite as much but it
also made me think like this is something that i've heard elon musk talk about a little bit with x
is that he kind of wants it to be the all-in-one app for the us you know have payments have chatting
have social media that sort of thing and um you know i don't know if he's going to pull it off
it doesn't seem like it at least that we haven't moved towards that direction uh very substantially
in the time that he's been running it but um the vision is there right you know that that model is
validated in lots of other countries um so it just kind of made me think like hmm the x's seems to be
the only one that is actually really aggressively going after that so maybe it'll happen yeah yeah maybe
it will happen i don't know it's interesting i i still find myself feeling that twitter is in like
a extremely niche and becoming more niche social network where like the people who do use it are
already like at a certain point in terms of like social connectivity like you know random you know
boomer is probably not like going and signing up for twitter today you know what i mean like maybe they
are but i think it's more like younger people who are like hooked into social media already who are
signing up as like twitter users more than like people who are like hmm let's see what's on twitter
today you know what i mean like but maybe i'm wrong about that i don't know yeah i don't know they'll
definitely take more research um but i i think i think just the fact that x has that vision is pretty
cool um yeah i don't know we'll see where it takes i'm i'm a big fan of x i i use it pretty regularly
it's my top social media i get a lot of the the stuff that we talk about on the podcast from x so
um yeah i don't know it could be cool all right sorry back to your back to your book anyways anyways
okay so cacao cacao is um you know very uh large um software company company in general in korea
um cacao chat very large probably the the most popular chat app in south korea um so there was a
really interesting chain of bugs that this researcher found so essentially it started out with the fact
that there was a deep link that could be used to open um somewhat arbitrary urls and it had javascript
enabled um so that's always interesting because javascript enabled means that you can potentially do
an excess you have an xss so there are a couple different attack vectors mainly you know javascript
interfaces or potentially redirecting the user to an arbitrary url but even then you kind of need to
chain that with something else um and uh there was a couple other interesting things that they had
noticed like that you could use in 10 ur eyes which i don't think is enabled by default so that is a
little odd um and i don't actually think that they ended up using that so it was interesting they
they called it out but i don't think it was part of the final exploit but it is pretty interesting uh
thing to check for just to see if it's you know possible because as they as i noted it would allow
you to interact with non-exported um parts of the app um via javascript through like you know
redirecting them to url so it's it's an interesting attack vector um but basically what they found is that
if you hit this specific uh url scheme it would open a ur like a set url with like something following
the path um and so they tested a bunch of things and one other thing that they noticed was that you
could leak the auth token to basically any url with something so it's it's like one of those um short urls
or one of those yeah so like example colon slash slash host and then that would take you to like
example.com slash host slash blank okay okay so it's allowing you to open up in the web views
it's allowing you to control somewhat what what is being opened up in the web view right right
somewhat yeah so pretty interesting um and uh so they were like all right well we have javascript
functionality and we have this you know somewhat controllable url like let's see if we can do this
and there was a check function that they looked through and basically it was strict enough that
they couldn't really find some way to like bypass the parsing so they would have to do essentially a
secondary vulnerability like an open redirect or something like that um so sure enough they find
an open redirect uh on this subdomain specifically so um the the way that this worked was the it would
actually take them to a subdomain with like a clean path so that the path wasn't set on the url
it was just taking them to a specific subdomain with like arbitrary path um so they found a path
underneath this host that would allow them to do an uh an open redirect to any any other host within that
root domain okay so this is like the semi-closed redirect that we were talking about i don't need
to talk so obfuscated here because it's all on the blog post so yeah let me let me try and clear
it up so basically cacao talk colon slash slash buy takes you to buy to cacao.com slash path right um
and then they found an open redirect under buy.cacao.com that would take them to any cacao.com url
uh allow them to read it to any you know subdomain under cacao.com right yeah so then they search even
further like okay so we can hit this deep link we can use the open redirect on that subdomain to now
go to any url within the root domain how do we escalate this um and and one thing i mentioned
uh i don't know if i fully got through it but they've noticed that the auth token gets set on
every request so it doesn't matter if they're specifically going to a cacao domain in that web
view if they request to any host including an attacker control url that auth token gets sent as
a header dude this is this is something that i see fairly often in a mobile environment i wonder why
that is do you do you know why they like it's just some when i think about it from like a web
perspective i'm like okay there's like some sort of service worker sitting in place there just adding
the auth header to every single request is that something you see pretty often in mobile like yeah
so one of the one of the things i um i actually covered this a little bit in the recent ssl um unpinning
master class that i did but um retrofit is a very popular um android uh like request library and i think
it's a good good example for this because it has this concept of interceptors and basically an
interceptor runs on every single request that goes through the request factory and it'll you know add
headers check various things whatever add off all that kind of stuff so what's my guess is what is
happening is that they just have a generic interceptor that adds off to every single request because the
assumption is it's never going to be possible to hit any url that's attacker controlled so it's not even
like on their radar but all it takes is you know some crafty you know work here and you know now
now you can figure out how to get right because they weren't expecting oh there's an open redirect
somewhere else on this on the subdomain domain right um so with that open redirect they can get to any
root domain they keep digging they do some google dorking and they find i found this very interesting
they found a dom invader canary that was like cashed by google and they're like oh that looks like that
looks like a dom invader uh canary so they it ended up being an xss it's like a dom xs like a or like a
stored xs has um that like popped an alert and they're like okay well actually i think it might
well i guess it's a dom xs yeah i think it's a dom xs yeah they call it a stored but uh i think it's
dom xs um anyways so they they keep digging they keep digging they find another endpoint um where
this you know search parameter whatever is getting passed in and they get uh you know another dom xss
basically so they find a bypass on a different endpoint and get a functional uh dom xs on this
separate subdomain um it's what is it m dot shopping how dot cacao dot com um so now they have an xss
on a different subdomain and they have a way to redirect to that subdomain and they have a way to open
that redirect through a deep link so what the what you would do is like you know as as an attacker like
or the victim or whatever like you send them a link through the chat and they click on that link and that
link uh is a deep link that opens the by you know cacao talk colon slash by that redirects everything
after that to the open redirect which then triggers the open redirect goes to a different subdomain
which pops the xss which then open uses that javascript execution to send them to an attacker
controlled url which then loads the attacker controlled page with your auth token being sent
automatically and now the attacker has your your auth and it's one click atl dude that is quite a flow
so deep link to open redirect to xss which is essentially just a client-side open redirect in this
scenario um and then which is fine because javascript is set to enable in the web view and then uh
then it it redirects to an attacker control domain which is where that that piece you mentioned where
the auth header gets added to every request comes in and you just snag the victims off right it's
basically like a limited redirect to to an open redirect to an ato because the first one only lets
you go to domains within cacao.com but then by pivoting that to an xss you use the xss to actually just
set set the target url like they're literally just setting document dot location yeah exactly so it's
not like anything crazy um they're just sending them to the attacker control url because the attack
vector is that the token gets set as like a header automatically so all they need to do is load the
url dude that's that's pretty freaking sick this is a great this is a great example of a mobile attack
chain yeah well i was gonna say like you know a lot of the times like you know you get very caught
up in like the weeds on like um you know trying to find a javascript interface or something but
sometimes it's the very simple behavior like this like setting the auth token on every request and one
thing i liked is that they included a way for you to test this um where well most of the way to test
this i have a i have a little free to gadget that i love that i use all the time that globally sets
all web views to be debuggable um and if i notice that something has a web view one of the first things
i do is i run that script so that i can use the chrome inspect tool uh to attach to it and check
stuff like this right one of the things you can do is you can literally just open the console in the
chrome inspect uh on the device and you do document location equals you know attacker url.com and then
you check the request and you see did it send a token anywhere and if you did then you go okay now
you're looking for open redirects you're looking for arbitrary url you know like arbitrary url uh opens
like that kind of stuff because all you need to do is load one attacker control page and it's it's ato
the the another takeaway for me here is that any deep link that results that interacts with a web
view or controls the destination that a web view will be sent to is extremely interesting and should
be very thoroughly vetted because anytime you can control that sort of thing once again we're just
weaponizing redirects and we're getting gadgets in our pocket that we can use in full attack chains
and and i think i think we mentioned this uh last episode or the episode before but um i think
there's a lot to be said for going and finding the gadget that you need like i i think oftentimes
as we start looking for gadgets there's like a couple levels of that and it's like oh you identify
a gadget great i'll have it in my pocket and i'll use it whenever i i find you know just happen to
stumble upon the other piece that i need but then the next level is like okay i've got this gadget
how can i force this gadget to work right and you go and you find the open redirect you you don't just
give up on this on the closed redirect or whatever that that uh or semi-open redirect that they found
that allowed them to get to a different um domain uh subdomain within the same uh top level domain
and you you push it further and further and further until you find the xss and pop the full attack chain
really really good write-up i like this a lot yeah yeah absolutely um i i totally agree i think it's one
of those really good cases that shows um that you don't necessarily you don't need like full mobile
skills like to to find like a really impactful mobile bug like a lot of the times it relies on
stuff like this like open redirects and and just like standard xss to get that full attack vector and
it doesn't need to be anything crazy like oh like all the stars have to align to open an arbitrary rail
like all you need is some web view that has javascript um execution in some way to uh even
get like partial control of that url or get javascript execution within there like um you know
opening it to like a product page that has an xss payload or something like you know there's a lot
of different ways where this can manifest so um you know just thinking creatively and outside of the box
and having those gadgets in your brain uh will let you let you get there it's another it's another thing
as well it's another reason that you should try to expand your abilities as a hacker you shouldn't
just stay in your lane right because marginal mobile skills like like i'm very confident that
i could have found this bug if i was looking at this app right um because all it takes is knowledge
of deep links and with that's something we covered in our mobile episodes back on like episode eight or
something like that and uh it's stuck in my head ever since and then everything after that is
essentially just uh web hacking um so just just a little bit of knowledge in your target area
combined with your current expertise can really allow you to to pop some very impactful bugs so um
i will say one last comment that i had on this as you were talking through it i was reading uh through
the the blog it says we reported this vulnerability in december 2023 to cacao's uh bug bounty program
however we didn't receive any reward as only koreans are eligible to receive a bounty
which is like so messed up dude and it's it's it's very interesting i have a feeling there's some
weird um there's some weird financial regulations or who knows what yeah it's um that is i just got
an unfortunate but but um maybe maybe you can find a friend at korea yeah exactly just dm it to your
korean friend hey man you want 500 bucks yeah it's a good time to make friends in korea exactly exactly and
i think actually we were trying to find someone mentioned in the in the critical thinking discord
was like hey is anyone here korean you know because it's like i need someone from korea to do something
and really okay that's great yeah i dig it um all right dude once again we are 30 minutes in and still
on the second news item so i'm gonna breeze through this next one pretty quickly um this next one is a um
um a write-up on essentially secret based um or time-based secrets uh and being used for various
uh different things like password resets and and that sort of thing um it's called reset tolkien
which is just an absolutely amazing name uh one token to rule them all uh a play on um on jr tolkien um
um jr now i'm kind of j yes yeah jr r tolkien that's i i forgot nar i was like wait a second do i
know things about uh literature do i know anything besides hacking um uh yeah so cool cool name cool
write-up i dig it i'm intrigued i'll i'll click you know i'll click uh and essentially i read through
it it's pretty long um the the author does a really good um job of sort of addressing the methodology used
throughout this whole research um so i'm going to condense it down to top tips and tldrs for you
here uh and essentially those are that you should be on the lookout for anything that uses php's unique
id function i think we mentioned this in the php episodes as well um that is uh not secure and
generated based off the current time and date and also mongodb's object id uh is also not secure and is
based off of a time stamp a process id and a counter um so that that can also be uh uh guessed
with a decent amount of accuracy um and the other tip that i had in here uh that was just kind of in
this nice little blue tip box which was awesome which is anytime you're doing any sort of time-based
attacks um against a a server there is this mandatory header that must be returned with every single
request called date um and that is the current server time uh and so that is really helpful if
you're trying to figure out okay what time does the server think it is if they're generating these sort
of um uh time-based tokens and so you can use that date header uh to perform various operations and
that's exactly what the author does they create this tool called um i think it's called reset token yeah it
is it's called reset token and essentially it does something that i've actually had success with in
the past which is uh it takes the current date from the server which is which is awesome using that that
date header you just copy and paste the date header into the tool and you give it a token and you give
it some data about your account like your email that sort of thing and it will try um six different
formats uh with a bunch of different hashes a bunch of different um uh flows to see if they can get
a a collision with the hash that you provided so let's say you do a password reset you get the date
on on that you pass it to the thing you give the password reset token you give it your email
and it's just going to brute force you know milliseconds backwards most seconds forwards uh you know
sha one sha 256 uh you know timestamp plus your email sha 256 concatenate you know and then shortened
you know all these different combinations to see if you can get a collision and um i just wanted to
shout out that because i think that's awesome and i would love to see some more community contributions to
uh the the structures that they have in there because there's only six currently and i think they're
pretty good but there's only six um and i also wanted to say that i've talked about this on the podcast
before but i have found this bug this was one of the first bugs that i ever one of the first criticals
i ever submitted um was a password reset token that was being generated by md5 uh of the user's email
plus the current unix timestamp and i just guessed that dude i guess i looked at that i did i guessed it
and i was like and i was like man i feel like that's an md5 hash and i feel like they're just doing
email plus it is just like one of those scenarios of just that's not normal no it was like some
serious psychic shit happening here like they're very kind of crazy and on that one time i wrote
the python script to generate it and somehow it actually worked on that same target and um and so
they are out there they are out there for sure uh so i'm i was excited to see this actually put into
practice and i think this could make a really good kaido extension or burp extension where um you're
able to select a a tool or like a specific token and pass it to the tool and see if there are any
results come back i think that'd be pretty awesome yeah yeah absolutely that's uh that's really crazy
yeah that's uh it's such a good tip yeah and i think i think also just regarding this um
james kettle will also be james kettle retweeted this which is why it kind of popped into my feed and
i think he's doing some timing based stuff uh and i wouldn't be surprised if he also uses this
really cool tip with the date being in the response um header and and um using that to do some other
time-based attacks yeah i will say like i feel like there's a bunch of attacks that probably 10 years ago
15 years ago would have been like theoretically this is possible but we don't really at scale it would take
too long now we have very powerful computers and ai and all sorts of fancy things that can optimize these
problems and make them more solvable and um we're starting to see like actual pocs for these things
coming out now um and so all the old systems that are stuck around that uh we're like yeah that'll never
be exploited it's what is it it's it's rsa like it'll be fine um and so now uh here we are so it's
uh it's really interesting to see this type of research and i'm excited to see uh more of this kind
of stuff yeah yeah same man it's definitely yeah scary to see where all that stuff will go um all
right you want to do the ios uh the next ios one or should i talk about the uh django one yeah so i'm
gonna i'm gonna try this ios one because it's uh it's kind of complicated to understand um and and
i've i've sat here like reading through it a couple times and i'm just like you know uh i don't know
it's still a little bit confusing to me so i'd recommend that you go and read through it but
my understanding is that essentially um if you you've probably seen it well you don't have an iphone but
if you have an iphone thank you you've probably seen this thing where um you go to sign in to
i don't know like with google or something into some app and you click that and it opens up a web
view and it says you know x x would like to sign in would like to use google.com to sign in and it
will like open this url and it'll do this whole sign-in process um and so uh there's some you know
miss checks on the back end when there's multiple apps that register the same auth like url like
redirect scheme basically with the with the authenticated web view like pop-up thing and so
you can use an attacker domain to redirect to that url it will go through the normal auth flow like if they
have a session there it'll like say yep and then you can also use prompt equals none um which was i guess
the the big like key to make this work to allow it to uh essentially skip through any sort of user
confirmation or verification or anything like that so just like opens verifies skips right through
sends the code to the attacker domain and then continues on um so it's uh it was super super
interesting i don't actually know what the fix was because they said that in the mitigation they go
app store review is not a mitigation here um so i don't know if there is an actual mitigation that
has been implemented that they mentioned was instead of using um some of these other uh links i forget
what the other ones are called that are just the domain name reversed instead use universal links uh so
the quote here would be apple offers universal links that are not hijackable meaning an attacker would
not be able to retrieve the uh redirect with the authentication code um there you go so that's the
redirect which sounds a little bit more like the android flow yeah and i will add a couple things
to this because i did get the chance to go through this one so um custom url schemes that's the thing
that that you're not supposed to use um for for this that that are hijackable like you said they apps
can register multiple diff like multiple different apps can register these um and i think there was a a
a fix put into place for that but essentially what they what they did now is using this as web
authentication session um feature uh to authenticate using the cookies that are active inside of the safari
app inside of your app instead of your malicious app um is what i think triggered this whole thing
and essentially when you use that as web authentication session thing it will pop open that little that
little uh prompt that you mentioned that i have never seen because i never use an iphone
uh um and and then but it'll say like hey you know we're trying to authenticate with like um this
is evan connelly's write-up uh in in conjunction with um julian uh mr tux racer um and so the the
screenshot that he has there is like you know oafi wants to use evanconnelly.com to sign in and the
user would say okay sure but then as soon as you open evanconnelly.com that that uh you can just
redirect since you control that domain you can just redirect to like google.com and do the prompt none
like you said and with the when the callback happens it'll automatically go back to your app
that triggered that that start so it requires you to have a malicious app on the device and then it
requires you to set up this sort of redirect inside of this web view um that is defined via this as web
authentication session functionality um and that allows you to hijack the the code when it comes back
which can be used to do account takeover in a ton of different environments so i think they said like
30 apps or something were vulnerable to this and uh because they're not using the universal links
instead they're using the the custom um url scheme yeah and i want to say there was an interesting
discussion i saw on twitter somewhere right either it was from evan connelly or evan had chimed in
or something that was discussing um the severity evaluations of mobile app uh bugs especially ones
that require uh an app to be on the device um and that's always definitely like a tricky scenario
because and again uh we've talked about this like we talked about this a couple episodes actually for
last episode or so where you know it'd be really interesting to see some data from people like
google and apple somebody posted it did you see that oh did they yeah no uh did they find the data
i think it was in the critical thinking discord or maybe it was twitter or something i i don't remember
exactly where it was but someone heard you say that in the past episodes and tracked down like
uh some data on that that somebody had released uh i i should have saved it and sent it to you i i
thought you would have seen it um but essentially it's pretty common that that that was the essentially
the tldr that was attached to that comment was yeah it happens all the time that that a malicious
app is actually on a user's device so um i think oh yeah here it is from evan yeah and it's a link
from facebook on latest pod you all said you were interested in research on the frequency of malicious
mobile apps making through app store review this is something i came across and used to make our case
when we needed uh with the ios oauth uh account takeover attack in short it seems to happen fairly
often and then there's a quote from this uh this is a um a post uh from meta's own blog uh in october
of 2022 that says our security researchers have found more than 400 malicious android and ios apps this
year in 2022 that were designed to steal facebook login information and compromise people's accounts
these apps were listed on the play store and apple's app store and disguised as photo editors games vpn
services business apps and other utilities to trick other people into downloading them so
400 malicious did i say 400 million no you said 400 malicious yeah okay yeah 400 malicious andrew so
that's across android and ios 400 it sounds like a lot uh but um when you think about how many apps
there are it's like you know what there's probably actually millions of apps right so but that's only
that's only focused towards attacking meta right so so that's that's kind of interesting and and and
and i think which is like one of the top five largest companies in the world but yes so you know
yeah like i will say like it it for sure happens right like and if there's going to be a target it's
going to be facebook google twitter like probably right like those are like at least facebook and
google are going to be so and apple probably are going to be like your top three like target microsoft
right i totally agree um but uh that being said i i think i'd like to see what that means like 400
again like it sounds like a lot i'm not saying 400 is not a lot um but i would be really curious to
know like an install count or something like how many like okay like how many yeah what's the install
count for that now compare that to the total install counts of all the apps during 2022 what
percentage of installs were malicious apps yeah what percentage of devices have had a
malicious app installed on them in the past three years or something like that right yeah exactly and
like i know these are really hard things to quantify so i'm not expecting anybody to have an answer um
but i that's i think what especially from from like a program perspective like if that article works
and that numbers like if that's what you need to prove it like rock on like but um i from like the
program side would be really interested for like the threat evaluation to see some like in perspective
statistics again on like what that means and what that looks like in like the overall picture and like
what the risk is uh as a whole yeah i totally agree i i think that'd be really interesting area um
one one last thing i wanted to mention on this the super cool ios uh awa thing um one of course the
prompt none super helpful please keep that in your brains prompt none works on so many different
implementations uh of course the prerequisite of that is that the user has to already have authorized
a certain application or whatever um but was it prompt none in the awa thing that we talked about
last week as well or was that separate i don't remember we'll have to go back and check um but the the
last thing that i wanted to mention was that this this so you mentioned being able to multiple apps
be able to register the same scheme and in android if i understand if i remember correctly it like if
it's trying to redirect back it'll prompt you to select the app that has precedent to to have um the
callback for this specific uh custom scheme or whatever um and it mentions in here that with the as
web authenticated session piece the reason why it doesn't do that is it's because whichever app
originated that auth flow inside of the web view will get the call back uh if they have that scheme
registered without any any sort of prompting or any sort of other reprioritization um so that's another
that's another one of the problems with that whole flow is like that's not great um so hopefully apple
will will go ahead and get this get this fixed if not in the meantime you know i imagine mr tux racer
and evan connelly have kind of cleaned this up across uh various bug bounty programs um and and i did
i think they were discussing it in the critical thinking discord um i think they said that this
was most of the time accepted as a high and uh and there were some scenarios where it was dropped to
a medium or a low but of those you know 30 probably at least 20 accepted it as a high which i think is
pretty rad um and kind of speaks to the the impact of doing this sort of larger scale research on
applications that can be applied across the board so very very cool for sure yeah um so real quick i did
go find the link uh from last episode it was um specifically it was um the zoom account takeover bug
um and it was not the same thing it was the fact that you could set response type to code comma id token
to multiple values so i think i would love to see some research on this but even uh if you don't decide
to publish it i think it it would be a very worthwhile time investment to go take a look at oauth
take a look at the open uh id oauth implementation available parameters take a look at the spec take
a look at where it's possible to send multiple values where it's possible to send values that are
optional um and either write some tooling or add in your testing flow to be testing for these things
like prompt none sending multiple things to response type um sending you know uh what is it um client uh
uh the the response token is that what you're talking about uh yeah id credentials um as the uh
as the token type or whatever um you know there's a lot of different things that you can test here
um and i think it's uh it seems to be a really ripe area for research yeah yeah i agree and i i will say i
now that you mentioned that i i did go back and look at the zoom right up and they actually do say that
just not very explicitly they say quote meanwhile in window b the oauth flow takes place as we
have modified the prompt parameter to no longer ask the user to select an account everything will
happen automatically and if you look at the exploit code they're using um prompt none for that uh in
the at the very end of the window b's location sort of piece there um so yeah i think i think that is a
a killer tip the prompt none and then um this this additional additional piece uh about understanding
the mechanics surrounding um how oauth is implemented inside of a ios application i think ios applications
are a little bit tricky too a lot of people can do more android stuff than ios so props to them for
going after ios stuff yeah yeah totally um all right so i'm gonna hop over to um another write-up that
will be the last one for our news section today um and that is uh some research that just came out i
want to say yesterday or day before yesterday um on orms uh and this research is done by ltam um more
specifically alex brown um i've seen a lot of cool stuff come out of ltam so that's pretty rad um and
this whole concept of uh object uh relational mappers or orms are often found in crms um such as django and
that sort of thing um and essentially they are layers of extraction on top of the database so that you can
connect your uh various types of databases oh yeah yeah from the developer so yeah like anytime i'm
doing any work with the database i'm always using an orm um you know it's basically just like you
create a class and you say like here's the fields here's the type of those fields and then through
magic orms it does all that in the database and it creates those relationships between classes and
objects so you can just be like get me 50 of this and it'll be like here's a class with all the
attributes and everything that are set to these field values that are and it's all stored in the
database and it all there's for the foreign keys work and all that kind of stuff so it just makes
working with databases really nice it does but it also adds another layer of abstraction and extraction
is dangerous uh because you don't exactly understand what's happening at the lower level
sometimes especially if you're you know more junior developer or something like that um so the the
tldr of this write-up and you should absolutely go read it because i think this applies to a lot of
different um frameworks and and structures uh orms as joel mentioned is a pretty popular sort of uh
abstraction on top of the database um so i could definitely see this happening in other different
areas and the writer here um the author of this this write-up uh describes a couple scenarios where
it's like okay you know now we need to be able to filter on various fields inside this thing and they
keep on changing the field so now we're just going to make it filterable on every field and um
essentially what's happening here is if if there is a situation which there was in django or orm where
uh you're able to supply a specific um a json blob which then gets passed directly into the filter
piece of this orm you may be able to uh specify filter chains of sorts um essentially supplying arbitrary
parameters to this filter function and as like this is a common theme that i've seen across a lot of
different exploits is like any scenario where you are able as the user to provide arbitrary parameters
uh like um keyword parameters uh call arbitrary functions with no defined parameter you know that
sort of thing like we saw with the indirect object invocation um from the github enterprise or um the name of
the game nowadays is parameter testing parameter fuzzing yeah like finding those uh those things
that the developers are using behind the scenes uh that are sent in internal api requests and um
weren't supposed to be seen by the public yeah absolutely and and this this whole thing kind of
reminds me of the reflection or uh indirect method invocation thing that we discussed with the github
enterprise bug um but essentially what it's allowing you to do here is filter off of any um any field and
what it will allow you to do then is provide things like password underscore underscore starts with
where underscore underscore is a specific filter or selector on that field um and then the the author
also shows how so obviously using that if it provides any response you can get it to do like a true or false
response um even if it's not returning that password you can determine what that character is um line you
know um by by just brute forcing all the the possible character space uh line by line uh or character by
character and um the exploit that they wrote is really really beautiful so definitely check out the
write-up and look at those gifs on seeing a password hash just appear on your screen one character at a
time it's just super like you know hacker porn essentially there um uh but the the write-up was really
good and it also shows how you can chain these so how in django rm you're able to to say like okay for
every article um the article that was created by and that references to like the user object and then
you can select the user's password and then underscore underscore contains or like underscore
underscore starts with or whatever the set of filters that they have um can be applied to these fields
which can allow you to leak the the output character by character um and then one last thing on this was
was was that uh even if you don't have something that provides like sort of a boolean output uh whether
you have a match or not um the author was able to utilize uh regex um dos essentially to tell you whether
you have select successfully selected a character so you'll instead of defining you know underscore underscore
contains you have some sort of regex that's in place that when it matches it will cause a regex dos which
will stall the system until you have the correct character yeah it's such a it's such a creative
way of like basically doing like a sleep uh or like a sleep based or error based uh like injection
uh where it's basically you're doing a uh like a a look behind or a look ahead um and then after that
you're doing like a really intensive regex that's going to take a lot of time or it's going to time out
and so if it matches and like proceeds then it's gonna you know error and if it you know just exits
really quickly then it's not a match exactly exactly so um i think this is a really cool technique that
i've seen used by super elite hackers in a lot of context is this sort of character by character
um exfiltration and even usage of error-based um implementations of this sort of thing so
uh definitely kind of have that in your brain as you're thinking about um the structures of some
of these apis and if there is any functionality that allows you to search or like provide specific
characters or like regex something um you often see these used in in cross-site leaks as well um
definitely be on the lookout for these uh is the big takeaway uh for me yeah yeah totally um all right
uh let me see i'm gonna take a look at the notes really quickly here yeah i the only other thing
that i had here is like this sort of makes me think of graphql related stuff on how they're hopping from
object to object within the database um and this orm mapping sort of allows you to do that so um any
scenarios you know we see that in graphql all the time where it's like okay you know i can't access this
user object directly but if i go through like the article and then created by and then author and then user
yeah then i can't access this so any any type of times where you can do chains of um various object
relationships i think that area is sort of ripe for vulnerabilities because the complexity goes way up
from the on the development side and it it's hard to sort of think of all those scenarios
yeah yeah totally totally um all right so that's the news and now we're in um and and now we're gonna
go ahead and move to a uh community bug submission um and for those of you that aren't aware of this
essentially we offer to the critical thinkers tier on discord um the ability to submit a bug that they
might want to have featured on the podcast and if that bug is selected then we're gonna go ahead and
air it on the podcast and sort of discuss it as well um and very apt for uh today's uh podcast this uh
community bug submission is by evan connelly the same guy that did the ios uh oauth write up so uh
congrats for absolutely crushing it lately evan you've been rocking it um and we'll go ahead and
jump into that uh that explanation of the bug by him now hey everyone my name is evan and this is my
first bug bounty bug so back in 2019 i just got a tesla model 3 and i came across the fact they had a bug
bounty program where you could register the vehicle and they'd pay for findings and so that just seemed
so cool to me and for whatever reason i just became a goal of mine that i was going to find a bug not
just in their program but specifically with the vehicle and so this led to a deep dive i was going
through all of the diagrams for the electrical diagrams and schematics all that kind of stuff
and i just needed to understand how does this thing work what are all these different components
what's this do and i spent a whole lot of time looking at the diagnostic ethernet port so that
was readily accessible within the cabin you could plug a laptop in and it just seemed like a good way
to get in but banging my head against a whole lot because it was locked down pretty well with a firewall
and there really wasn't a whole lot of interesting traffic you couldn't really reach anything do anything
interesting there but i was determined i am going to find a bug and so it's like this stubborn
determination of i don't care how unlikely this seems i don't care how unqualified i feel like i might
be to actually do this i am going to find a bug and i will just keep trying until i do and so at some
point it occurred to me maybe i should try to look at the same port in different states like specifically a
software update what would happen if i'm plugged in during a software update maybe like momentarily
i'll see something interesting or something reboots or something like that and so i tried that i sat in
the car for like half hour during a software update and honestly i ended up just seeing less activity but
then at the end of that software update i'm plugged in and all of a sudden i've got wireshark open and it
just starts it explodes like i'm seeing packet after packet after packet and so i get that feeling we all
know when you find something cool it's like your heart skips a beat and you're like i did it and
start looking through all that there's http traffic from different hosts within the car it just seems
like there's a whole lot of potential here and you know part of me is immediately like all right well
now i need to report this but i forced myself to slow down did some more research i believe over a
few days and i was able to understand a whole lot more about these different hosts within the car what
they do some of the unauthenticated api endpoints and there was one where you could actually download
all the configuration values from the infotainment system and so i'm looking through all these different
parameters and i also found one where you could change these values and so as i'm doing all that
i come across one in particular it's super interesting it was remote start and so i try it and sure
enough you can set remote start to true and so with that i try it and now there's a pop-up on the
infotainment system i can see that remote start has occurred and i end up testing this a few more
times with no key present it turns out through this method there was a 24-hour period after any software
update where you could digitally hotwire a tesla you could plug a laptop in i even demonstrated it with
an ipad and just through hitting an unauthenticated api endpoint you could hotwire that car and drive off
with no key card present and so uh with that then i had this really cool way of presenting it to tesla
i got that report in and come to find out um you know as everyone does as i still do looking at that
bounty table expecting full bounty they come back to me and they gave me i believe 3 500 but the
reasoning was it was a dupe but despite being a dupe they paid it out anyway because of the impact that
i showed and so two lessons there have stuck with me i think even help with web apps crub could maybe
help with somebody else first off is just that persistence of i'm gonna bang my head against a
wall i don't care how many times i have to try i'm gonna keep trying until i find something and with
that checking all those different states you know does this change if it's in this state or that state
i think that applies a whole lot to web apps as well and then also showing max impact i think i'm
gonna slow down i'm gonna see what i can do with this i'm gonna see if i can escalate this but
presenting this in a way that's super compelling for the program those are two things i've tried to
apply ever since i think they've helped me a whole lot and so i just hope they help someone else as
well but that's my story there thanks for listening dang dude what a freaking bug oh it's cool the whole
time i was listening as soon as he was like oh there's this physical ethernet port i'm i'm thinking oh no
yeah like i know where this is going um because it's such a it's such a hard um you know like i
think with something like a car it's a little bit of a different attack vector um because there's like
it's like one of the it's like a physical thing where like you know you can just like bust a window
and the hotwire aspect is is a really strong attack scenario but if we're anything else um then like
remote start or something like you know maliciously like you know intercept like doing something during the
software update or anything like that like for sure they would have been like now mitigating factor
and the other funny thing was when he was like uh that that it got closed as a dupe um i have only ever
reported one bug to tesla no with sam curry and it was not the same bug but it wasn't also a dupe and
it ended up being that uh you know sam like picked me up at the airport uh in his tesla and i was just
like fiddling with the back and like uh immediately like found something and so we reported it and then
like a little while later we hear back and they're like hey uh this is actually fixed in the latest update
uh make sure that your car is up to date but sure enough we had to go out and update the car sam
hadn't done a software update on his car sam hadn't done a software update which is good because he was
avoiding a hotwire i guess yeah i guess so no that's that is really cool though um and i think i think
it's awesome the the tip that he said about um trying things in different states i think is really
cool especially for iot related stuff um things really do change during software updates on a pretty
regular basis for iot stuff so really great great takeaway there um tesla hacking tesla cars i don't
know man seems like there's a high due percentage there maybe it's just because people are very
interested in the technology so they spend more time looking at it or maybe it's because their patch
cycle is really slow but yeah i don't know definitely something to to be aware of um the other thing i
really liked from this write-up was uh his persistence how motivated he was he poured over
diagrams he spent hours he was really just hobbying it right um a lot of times bug bounty you kind of
think about oh well you know i'm not earning millions of dollars doing bug bounty i'm not succeeding
it's not the case like try to be a hobbyist about it you know before bug bounty people would just do this
shit for fun you know um and try not to get arrested yeah so so like try to be a little bit more
hobbyist about it i think is a good takeaway and then also he slows down and he shows full impact
once he has a a thing um a lead and i think this is an interesting thing because my experience in the
bug bounty arena has said uh just go ahead and report it like just i mean especially with something
like a car where they actually can't patch it you know without your permission just go ahead and report
it um and then add to the report when you had when you flushed out more impact uh and but but don't
stop right report it and then keep moving because i think it's easy for once you've kind of lost your
momentum a little bit when you went went and wrote the report or whatever to kind of like just wait and
then kind of get in that post report stall where you're like uh i reported it i want to see what they
say before i spend more time on it don't do that just keep keep building out that impact if
you think the the possibility is there and um so props to evan for for doing that fully i like that
yeah totally um all right well speaking of that mental aspect right yeah i think that's that's kind
of our topic for today right it is yeah we've we've got a good a good little um segment for that today
and actually we're already an hour in so we should be uh on the lookout for that but um i kind of wanted
to discuss staying sharp and motivated inside of bug bounty okay so i think there's a couple
there's a couple little segments that i've kind of broken this into one um you know staying sharp
and motivated and and two avoiding the opposite of that avoiding burnout avoiding um getting stagnant
or stale so we'll kind of take that from two angles but first i wanted to ask you something okay
so i was writing this out and i was like oh you know what are some of the common mistakes people
make you know that kind of get them disappointed and kind of get them in a rut with bug bounty and
i think one of them is sort of getting a really painful dupe or getting a really painful na or
informative and then just kind of sitting in that valley of sorrow you know um and i think maybe for
for people that are new to bug bounty that don't have a lot of self-confidence um in their abilities as a
as a book bounty hunter then it could be good advice to say like hey don't get your hopes up until you
see that that report moved to triage or until you see that bounty report um you know or bounty awarded
in your email um but for me as a more experienced hacker i don't know maybe it's just kind of like um
like like i need to feel something you know like like from bug bounty you know like i just i just want
to feel something man um but i kind of like to ride the highs and lows like i kind of like to as soon
as i find something freak out run tell my wife jump up and down scream and then you know when it's a low
i kind of like to you know flop on the ground and like take some time go sit in the hot tub drink my
coffee be all sullen or whatever and then you know move through it because i think it it kind of keeps
things emotionally charged for me which i think is more helpful in the long term so what do you what
do you think about all that i mean i guess it all just depends on like how you deal with and process
emotions right like some people it's uh better for them to just sort of like feel through it and let it
pass other people like i think generally trying to stay positive about it is is always a good thing
like i'm definitely not positive 100 of the time um i definitely like uh like i almost quit bug bounty
like a month ago so like i've definitely been there you know um but um i think uh especially
around dupes just one thing i want to note um is a lot of people see dupe as a failure a dupe is
literally like you literally found a valid bug like it's literally been accepted by the program it's not
a failure the only thing that failed is that you didn't get paid for it and the only thing that you
lost was your time um so there's nothing really that you can do about that but i would encourage
you to just you know try and stay positive that like you found uh you did find a valid bug that was
accepted by the program is you just got you know screwed over by timing um maybe i don't know just as
food for thought for some of the program people who are sorry the platform people who are listening
like from hacker one and whatever um it might be interesting to see some sort of root shift on like
the framing of duplicate and the fact that there's no award no nothing like at minimum listen if we're
giving freaking points for vdp like why aren't we giving points for dupes come on they give you like
two reputation points or something like that but i think i think they want they want to you know minimize
gaming of the system but it would be nice if there was some additional systems already game yeah
seriously but but i mean like it would be nice if there was some sort of additional like um yeah
framing around and surrounding and i don't have a great suggestion for it but like you said validating
showing that it's a valid bug like affirming the hacker that sort of thing and i will say you know
you mentioned you do lose your time which is true you know if you're looking at it from a monetary
perspective you do lose your time but um also as a hacker you kind of grow more with each bug and
you found a valid bug you submitted the report it got duped that is what it is but also that bug is a
valid bug in your repertoire as a hacker and you fully exploited that you submitted or you outlined
it in a report you went through the steps to do that so from like a hacker development perspective
it's not a loss uh but even though it can feel like a loss because your wallet isn't bigger
yeah yeah and like being failure reverse is totally normal um like i think that's a good instinct to
have of like not wanting to get a dupe and not wanting to like have something fall through like
that's totally normal um you know loss aversion failure version all that kind of stuff like it's very
very normal um so i don't know joe you and i you we've debated this on the pod before but whenever i hear
you say failure version is is a good thing like no i'm not necessarily necessarily saying it's a good
thing but it's a it's a normal thing it is and like to some extent it can be good like if you let
it control you then and like you ignore like like you need to be able to push through it in some cases
right like um in most cases i would say and yeah like it depends on the goal right like it depends on
what the what the outcome is and you know and probably in in the cases that we're talking about
for like bug bounty where it's like more of a mental thing than it is any like actual loss
um or like failure then it's like yeah like just you know the worst thing that happens is that your
bug gets closed uh or lowered in severity does that suck yes is that worth not reporting is that not
worth like not following through on it no like because the financial incentive is there's still like a
potential large upside yeah yeah i agree yeah it's it's a little bit tricky with the failure version
thing because my my my experience with failure version is like i think it's one of the things that
most people do not have the uh that muscle sort of developed and flexed and essentially the first
thing i tell all of my mentees is like listen you are going to fail 98 of the time as a extremely
talented hacker like as a top tier hacker your success rate is going to be like two percent on
the attack vectors that you implement right um and you know this varies with your uh you know if you're
doing white box then sure you might be more but um you know as a black box exter you have to test
everything you're gonna fail all the time um and it's it's gonna suck so you have to build out that
that whole concept of like a failure should be redefined as something where you where you can now
affirmatively say this doesn't work and cross that off the list and feel like you've made progress um
that that reframing is absolutely essential i think for staying sharp and motivated um and and on top of
bug bounty um yeah yeah i mean like we encounter quote unquote like failures all the time right it just
depends on how you view it it's like is testing for rce and command injection on like the id on the cmd
parameter if that doesn't work is that a failure yeah that's like that's like uh extremely that's
like role that's like gambling you know what i mean it's like uh you know don't get mad at yourself if
you lose at the casino because like it's literally like everything is a gamble everything is a test
but the difference between gambling and buying money is that you can actually learn from the signals
that you see in response and you can actually influence those and change them it's not completely
pure chance yeah yeah i agree um all right so let's move into the staying sharp and motivated
uh section and then we'll kind of move over to the the burnout avoidance um before we get into the
things that are actually like sort of bug bounty related uh do you know what a continuous glucose
monitor is i i do and when i saw cgm i was like is that what i mean yes it is what i mean that's like
what does he mean by this so it's like you know cgm might help with your your staying sharp and
motivated well that's what i'm saying like like so so i um i've got one sitting right over there but
i i got one the other day really yeah yeah i i had one in my arm for two weeks and i i got it just as
a way to monitor my blood glucose levels and see how i respond to various foods so i can get the huberman
one no i didn't i didn't i got one okay like prescribed through my doctor said hey can you prescribe
me one he's like sure um and so i i got it hooked up to the app and um and it was really interesting
to see like how fasting plus coffee gets me in this super like locked in uh focused state for a while
but then it sort of tails off towards the end and then what i found is so i eat a lot of rice because
we lived in japan and we got used to that diet and we just kind of haven't shifted away from it um
it and and so uh when i eat a bowl of white rice that just messes with me dude like my my blood glucose
levels just skyrocket and then plummet and i'm like you know why that is well i mean it's a it's
i mean explain it to me no i don't know why it is well it's all gluten yeah it's like yeah because
it's it's grain right so it gets converted it's from it gets converted from gluten into glucose and then uh
your body has like a massive sugar spike and then it has a massive sugar crash right after
um because there's no like you're going from nothing to something to nothing yeah and i know
those carbs all sort of break down into that and and so i didn't do as much analysis on it as i as i
should have because i got super busy in those two weeks but um i thought it was a really interesting
sort of experiment to say like okay this is how uh various foods at certain timings affect my body
and did like keep me in a state of being focused or in a state where i can't focus and i'm just super
exhausted and dying and falling over so um i i really recommend it i think mine i think i got four
weeks worth of uh continuous glucose monitors which is two of them um and it was only like 70 bucks um
which i think is a pretty good investment so uh recommend that to anyone who's interested in kind of
uh getting addressing this sort of sharpness and mental clarity do you do intermittent fasting so
yes sort of i i don't do it on purpose but i i don't normally eat breakfast and i don't eat late
at night after i don't eat after 8 p.m uh just as like a family thing um and so i end up doing roughly
an 8 16 intermittent fast um uh and so yeah i think it really helps i do eat lunch but i don't normally
eat till like two or three okay interesting okay so we have probably about pretty similar i don't i eat
once a day usually like but at like two or three yeah so i don't eat breakfast i don't eat lunch i
eat dinner at like three or four really and then like um usually what ends up happening though is i end up
like snacking a lot um after that um so that probably isn't great either but yeah i've always wondered what
my um glucose levels would look like just monitoring them because i don't eat anything until like the
late afternoon and i know that like i crash um pretty hard like and the same thing happens to me
where like i'll eat and then i'll crash and so like i it doesn't like improve my energy levels at all
when i eat dinner i just like i'm kind of putting off this eating a little bit because it's like okay
i know as soon as i eat i'm not going to be able to hack or i'm not going to be able to do anything so
it's like it's very important i think for me to understand okay what kind of um food should i eat
that keeps me sharp and and keeps me able to be engaged through the full work day um and to be
honest even if i didn't the productivity uh trade-offs in the morning uh are pretty strong like i i feel
like i i get at least eight hours worth of work done you know by like two or three by the time i
first eat um and so i i think it's really helpful but it'd be even more helpful if i could prevent
that crash and um that definitely depends on what kind of foods i'm eating and then also whether i'm
going for a walk or getting some exercise immediately following getting some food in me
yeah yeah and i think also just having like the right things around for you to have available like
for me um like my adhd makes it really hard for me to like plan or like food or like want to like
make food and stuff especially when i'm in the middle of stuff i hate getting interrupted and like
task like switching and stuff so um it's uh if there's like nothing readily available for me to
just like grab like a bag of like you know beef jerky or something like i'm just like i just won't eat
or i just like won't have anything until like i'm like starving yeah it's tricky it's something you
definitely got to be aware of and um i've got a buddy actually that recently started a business here
in richmond so if any of you guys are in richmond and are interested in this then dm me but uh he does
sort of a private meal prep yeah like exactly i've actually done this before have you really yeah
yeah yeah i used somebody for that back in california um and the pricing like wasn't bad at all
honestly the hardest thing for me was like the calories like a lot of these types of things are
generally like designed for people who are like trying to monitor their caloric intake so you're
gonna see like somewhere between four and six hundred maybe eight hundred calories per meal um and unless
you're eating like four of those a day uh you're not gonna hit like your normal consumption unless
you're trying to cut calories um so that can be a lot but like as little quick meals that you throw in
the microwave like you know it's up like either like have somebody you know deliver it to your door
or like do that on the weekend and like portion out like broccoli and bits of chicken and steak and
whatever whatever you eat and then just like throw it in little microwave food boxes and then stack them
in the fridge and you're good to go yeah yeah no absolutely and i think you know what my buddy does
is he he does it a little bit it's more of a high-end service um uh but still pretty pretty uh well-priced
i must say where he he will take in into account all those things so if you say okay i want you
know one meal that's 2 000 calories right you know right like if you're eating one meal a day or
whatever right then he can make that happen or if it's like i want smaller meals of this amount i want
these macros i prefer these meats you know that sort of thing um he can kind of make it happen uh to
a certain degree you know it's still got to make sense from him from like a a scale perspective i gotta
get the recipe for the 2 000 calorie meal you know that's that's me saying like you know because he does
have some customers he mentioned to me that are like pretty serious um you know bodybuilding
types that need to consume a lot of calories uh yeah and so um it all depends on what your your
individual diet looks like but now now we've kind of there's there marks the end of our edry huberman
lab uh critical thinking the point is like there are there are like a couple of things that i feel
very strongly about that like when i was younger i used to um i i didn't give a shit about what i ate
i give a shit about when or how much i slept um and i didn't give a shit about when or how much
caffeine i consumed yeah and those three things alone are like huge um
modifiers to how you're gonna feel every single day yeah like when you choose to drink coffee
like uh you should wait like probably an hour to an hour and a half after you wake up before you have
any any caffeine you shouldn't have any like at most or at minimum six hours before you go to bed
probably like eight to twelve um you should be sleeping at least six hours probably six to nine
depending on age gender etc and you should be going to bed and waking up at the same exact time
when i was in college i used to like go to bed and like i don't know like 3 a.m wake up at like six
like or like whatever like i was just like sleeping whenever however much i didn't like have alarms
go to bed at the same time wake up at the same time even on the weekends sleep enough respect your
sleep if you do not respect your sleep your sleep will not respect you and it will you up oh man
you wanna you wanna like lower your life expectancy start sleeping four hours a night like my goodness that
is uh yeah straight up i take my i take my whiskey neat my coffee black in my bed at three and i'm
gonna die three no no i i i go to bed at like 10. so um you can go to bed at 5 a.m if you do it every
night i wouldn't necessarily recommend it because yeah like you know there are still like circadian
rhythm things that like you know going to bed like when the sun comes out like third shift third shift
work is classified as carcinogenic in the us because it's so really bad for you yeah the the
hit tears your circadian rhythm is so bad that it gets it's shown to cause cancer um so you know like
there are there are definitely like certain things that you might want to avoid but i think like having
schedules and like standards for your sleep and routine is like probably the bare minimum you should
do for your body yeah no i i totally agree so keeping i guess bringing that all back around to the
topic at hand being aware especially if you're doing this full time um being aware of what your
you know what habits you're falling into place are falling into place when you're eating uh how much
you're eating what you're eating causing you know various uh effects on your energy i think is really
helpful for staying sharp and motivated um uh the next one that i had sort of on the list here is
competition and accountability when helpful so i think just pulling some of the top hackers uh that i've
i've spoken with uh over the over the past couple years um there are a lot of people that really
thrive off of the competition of bug bounty uh thrive off of the leaderboards thrive off of the live
hacking events it's it's something that keeps them really motivated and uh excited so um i think that
for the record i'm not one of those people by the way i kind of wish i was sometimes but um and i
think a lot of a lot of the really top people are um maybe i used to be at some point but i'm
definitely not anywhere yeah you know it can change with time too i definitely used to be more more
competition oriented and then i think um you know as you start to understand more the nuances of the
system of like oh wow i actually didn't really try that hard at that live hacking event and i placed
really well uh you start to realize that um there's a certain degree of it that is just being at the right
place at the right time yeah for sure that sort of thing um finding the right bug like absolutely but
but i mean there is absolutely results that that suggests the that people can do it on a on a regular
basis as well you know like pretty much every every uh live hacking event that i've seen fronds really
give it his all he's he's at the top you know um yeah for sure so i think that there's definitely some
some aspects of this uh so figure out what comp if competition motivates you set friendly
competitions with your with your um you know other hackers and if accountability could be motivating
for you then maybe something that i've seen attack uh you know full-time bug bounty hunters do is set
like set up an accountability schedule with other hunters um to be like okay making sure i'm getting
a certain number of hacking hours in per week and that sort of thing um and i've seen this be helpful
and it's been helpful for me in the past too when i've been trying to be um when i've been less
motivated to hack and wanted to perform so yeah you know tweet out your weekly stats or whatever like
keep track of it in a spreadsheet uh whatever you need to do to like help you stay on track or feel
like you're you know hitting the goals that you want to hit like um i think it's always good to set
goals so that you have some sort of objective um measurable marker on whether or not you've hit that
and when you're setting those goals make sure it is something that you can measure so
it and don't like being unfair to yourself don't be like i want to make 500 000 this week because
like one maybe you will but like the odds of you not are probably higher than the odds of you are
um and while that's a good goal to set it's kind of unrealistic and uh if you make ten thousand
dollars and then you compare that to the fact that you wanted to make 500 000 you'd be like wow
i really sucked and didn't hit my goal and it's like no bro you made ten thousand dollars this week
you're fine um so i think you know setting goals being realistic about them um and having a good
perspective for uh you know where your performance is and having measurable goals is is really important
yeah absolutely and that just goes to a lot of the whole self-help theory as well of like uh smart goals
or whatever and and so that's that is definitely applicable here as well um the next one that i had is
working on something interesting and or something that you're interested in and i kind of wanted to get your
take on this as as somebody who uh you know struggles with adhd and and weaponizes that in
and also uh feels the consequences of that um in your life um so i think if for me even as somebody
that doesn't really super struggle with that i think i perform much better when i'm super engaged in
something and if you have the the flexibility to be like okay i'm gonna go work on this thing and then
i'm gonna jump back to this thing and i'm gonna you know and as your sort of interest in certain tasks
ebb and flow if you have the flexibility to work on something that you're interested in i think your
brain is in more high performance mode in those scenarios um and i've definitely heard of people
that that have adhd being able to weaponize this pretty effectively yeah so i think like being able
to focus in on something is important like i think generally it is possible even with adhd to like
find interest in something but a lot of bug bounty and a lot of i mean a lot of everything that you do but
you know bug bounty especially relies around the mental that you have like during that moment like
you said when franz decides that he's gonna give it his all in an event he's he ends up in the top
five top ten top three because it's commitment right he's not there's no like oh let me do this other
thing he's committed like he is like head down committed and fully 100 150 giving it everything he has
to trying and finding the coolest best bugs that he can and he's working his brain in overtime to try
and you know make that happen um so a lot of it is around how you're mentally framing the entire
situation in your head are you taking this seriously is this a target you want to hack or is this are you
just like trying to find an xss um you know i think some like to some degree you do need that interest to
be like yeah okay i want i like i want to hack this target i want to find a bug here um if you're
somebody who does it full-time you're not going to find that for every target i'm sure so um there is
a whole other side to it which is like i'm i need i want to find this xss because i need to find this
xss for my stats and that's like a different you know but regardless like you need to have some sort
of motivation that like pushes you to hack on that target if you're like i don't want to be here the
whole time that you're hacking on that target you're not going to be really looking you're not
going to find um the gadgets and the and the the you're not going to notice the things that you need
to notice so i'm going to jump one item down in the list here joel um and say and say something that's
sort of contradictory to what i just said which is i think there's also a lot of merit in staying on the
same target longer than you feel like staying on the same target um yeah from a motivation
perspective because um what what it forces you to do is it forces you to look at a target from a
different angle and once you've done that a couple times and you sort of flexed that muscle it's not
going to feel like you're sharp and motivated the first time a couple times you do it right
but once you've sort of flexed that muscle a little bit you start to realize that you miss stuff
everywhere everywhere all over the place everyone does it's just a it's just a part of the breadth of the
the whole you know app ecosystem and and just how bug bounty works in general is you're going to miss
stuff um and that's why there's always stuff to find um so i i think forcing yourself to take a deep
breath sort of um write down or quantify what sort of things you've actually tried on this application
and what sort of things you haven't and then coming at it at a different angle in the long term will give
you motivation um payoff because you'll start to realize hey even when i feel like i've hit a wall
there is more there and i know that because it there was more there this time and this time and
this time and this time when i did it and um the evidence suggests that this is this case is no different
um yeah yeah what are your thoughts yeah absolutely well well and like this one thing that we talk about
all the time is taking notes and i think like taking notes in the beginning um or just like throughout
the whole process is really good for chasing down and like pushing yourself to whether it's a time
minimum um or just like taking really diligent notes and you know checking every single path or whatever
like um you know you you want like you said you want to push yourself to actually feel like you're done
before you move on with with something um but you also don't need to like be excessive with it so
that part of that is going to be a time thing as you hack more you'll gain that sense and you'll be
able to you know better judge when it's time to move on um but even you know even still like both of us
take notes everybody takes notes and and you know circles back and goes okay what didn't i look at here
um and having having a way to look at that is really important yeah i'll often take retrospective
notes too like i'll i'll like just go ham on a target for two hours and then i'll say all right
what have i learned about this target and i'll write that down and what i've actually started doing as i
started having some more um hard stop times uh just as my life became a little bit less flexible
um i i've started taking loom videos of myself talking about a target and and just i'll sort of just
brain dump on myself uh essentially try to give any information that will get future justin back in the same
headspace as he was um you know when he stopped attacking uh and and watching those videos as
soon as i start the next hacking session and that that really really helps um and and i think this
that one is specifically applicable for people that do part-time hunting and might not be able to hack
every day and might have to stop for longer periods of time having that in place as a habit will
allow you to reduce the amount of time that you spend uh sort of trying to reignite your
your your uh interest in a target and getting back in your flow state um so that's that's a great one
as well um the next two that i want to talk about uh gadgets and then goals and celebrations both of
these sort of speak to motivation and controlling your own motivation one recognizing when you found
a gadget and celebrating that win i think is really good um it will keep your momentum going it'll keep
you feeling like you're making progress even if you don't have a report to send in so we talked about
that a lot so i'm gonna leave that one there and then the other one is is goals and celebrations so
um my wife and i do this for every live hacking event that i do we select some sort of thing i'm
gonna do if i crush it at this live hacking event like all right i'm gonna you know my hot tub was one
of them uh you know that i really had to that was a stretch goal i had to really hustle for that one
um and you know sometimes it's as simple as going out to a super fancy dinner with me and her
um you know just going blocking off that time not thinking about money or anything just saying okay
this is a reward for a job well done um but defining those those goals and getting those in place and
time bounding those um really motivating for me uh to to get done what i want to get done yeah for sure
and again this goes back to setting good measurable goals for yourself that are realistic and that you can
achieve um dude this is a strategy i do every single day like if i have completed something
and i haven't put it on my to-do list i'll put it on my to-do list and check it off just to be like
yeah i did something today um like it's really important to feel completion and feel like you've
accomplished things and done things and made progress especially on those days where it feels
like you aren't right like if you feel like you like if you haven't submitted anything or you haven't
done x y and z like make a list of the things that you did do today and just go and check them off
and be like oh yeah actually i did do a bunch of stuff today um and you know just put stuff in
perspective because especially with bug bounty especially when you're working alone it's really
easy to just spend eight hours like focusing on your computer screen and then be like oh
shit it's three o'clock like i have no idea what i did today but i didn't submit anything so it feels
like i did nothing yeah yeah and i'll sort of share a vulnerable story about this i mean last night i
texted you probably 10 10 p.m saying hey man uh i didn't get the notes fully prepped for this episode
today like i normally do i'm gonna wake up early tomorrow morning and do it and the reason for that
was i got super fixated on a task yesterday and i was and it was a big task and i performed super
well on it i got a ton of work done on it and i i'm really grateful that that i did and that i was
that motivated on that day but i did not prioritize the thing that i needed to get done for this morning
and that has effects on it happens on you and it has effects on you know other people too luckily i
was able to get out of bed this morning and get another hour or so of prep in before the episode
but i think there's also something to be said about knowing what times you have flexibility and and
living in that flexibility especially as a full-time hunter that's a great benefit of our our sort of
life that we lead um but then also knowing hey there are times i need to write down my tasks and i need
i need to prioritize the thing that will that are time sensitive that will give me the most
you know output for my for my time and think about that really intentionally and then just crank it all
out you know and just hit it boom boom boom boom boom and i think wisdom sort of should dictate what
what time is what yeah and i think you'd be really hard-pressed to find anybody who like has never
procrastinated or has never like spent time doing something that they shouldn't have done like
it can be difficult i salute the people who can just immediately be like okay i need to work on this
thing i'm gonna go work on this thing regardless of what time or how i feel and go do that thing i'm
not one of those people either like i can depending on what it is i've definitely sat down and been like
shit i need to do this work thing for tomorrow and it's seven o'clock i sit down i open my laptop and i do it
because you know that's that's life sometimes right like you sleep in the bed that you make for yourself
so if that's something that's my fault and i put it off like absolutely um i'm you gotta own that uh
you gotta you know sometimes you you have to uh bite the bullet and you gotta do tough things because
uh you made a bad decision at a different time and that's the consequence um but not always right and
so um you know just this goes a little bit into the burnout stuff but like uh i think one really big
burnout philosophy i have is like don't be uh if your own if you're your own boss especially with like
free time uh don't be your own boss don't be like the guy who's just like
get back to work it's the weekend like get like you're allowed to have days off like i'm gonna need this
tbs report by saturday yeah yeah so i mean yeah a lot of um you know like be fair to yourself be
fair to your time be fair to your energy don't um you know there's a line that you should draw for
yourself in terms of where am i going to force myself and push myself to go beyond my limits um
um and it's okay to some days drop that line to a different level um and it's okay to have sick
days and it's okay to take time off and um it's okay to you know give yourself some some grace because
uh it's hard to be self-employed it's hard to work all the time and with bug bounty feel it can definitely
feel like especially full-time bug bunny it can feel like a rat race yeah where you're just like
constantly on the wheel and if you're not on the wheel uh you're not making money and you're not
submitting bugs and everything comes to a halt and um getting out of that mindset can be really
difficult it is it is it's tricky and uh yeah i totally second everything you just said about that
and and so i'm gonna i'm gonna jump through some of these other ones we kind of touched on
collaboration already but of course collaboration can really keep you sharp and motivated um uh working
with other hackers grabbing little tidbits and one note i will add on collaborations um if you want
to be a really good collaborator if that's something that you want to improve on as a hacker
uh take your partners bugs gadgets weird functionality take that really seriously
like if somebody sends you something says hey look at this this is kind of sketchy right
like and you get to it and you don't see the sketchiness right away don't just write it off like
try to see the sketchiness and try to iterate on that try to get excited with them about it
because we all have different lenses and especially if you're collaborating with someone you respect which
you should always do i think um then they might see something that you don't and you got to acknowledge
that um in addition so totally different angle but also work with high quality teams
high quality programs programs that are going to give you fast communication programs that are going to
validate your threat model uh your understanding of their threat model quickly because um that will
there's nothing more motivating than a program coming back and saying wow that report was a banger
you know like we're shaking in our boots over here you know and i i think if there's anyone from the
program side listening of course i mean joel is here so he knows what's up but um you know providing
that little bit of encouragement to the hackers saying you know and really playing into the how the hacker
wants to feel like oh you know that one really got us you know scrambling or something like that can be
a massive motivator for the hackers um and so working with teams that they give you that and for teams
make sure you're giving that to the hacker because that's one way for sure to keep loyalty to your
program yeah yeah i totally agree i mean it right it's like a two-way street you know um from the
researchers perspective like um somebody has to extend their hand first in a handshake you know
like um and both parties have to do it for it to happen and so it does take some some cooperation
and some you know um like i don't know i think a good analogy is like if you've ever had a conversation
with someone uh who like doesn't carry their side of the conversation it's never fun and it doesn't
feel like a fulfilling conversation you're probably not going to want to have another conversation with
that person and that goes the same way for a report like if you provide like very minimal like
just like shortened to the point unless you're consistently doing that type of research the the
program is probably not going to be like wow like great research but like if you go out of your way
out from the gate to like demonstrate that you're like a quality researcher there's a lot of like thought
and time and effort and energy put into your hacking like the program will acknowledge that should
acknowledge that and and respect that and um appreciate that first first impressions and bug bounty are also
important you know yeah that first that first report comes through with a real with a real banger as
much as you feel like a dad on this episode i'm just giving life tips sleep at an appropriate time
justin and joel your bug bounty dad drink coffee that sounds like we're a gay couple like
your bug bounty dads uh no um so we're both married uh not that there's anything wrong with that but uh
yeah uh so anyway the the last thing that i had on the list here um was routinely reducing the friction
in your workflow right um and i wanted to to talk about this one because there's friction in everybody's
workflow right um there's there's areas where uh you are having to do something manually you're testing
something um uh that just takes more time to go through the the hoops to do it uh and there's
there's some way that you can automate it and make it better uh and i think one of the things that
really helps me from a motivation perspective is taking the time every couple weeks whenever i see
these sort of things popping up just dropping them in my uh certain project in my to-do list um
um uh and actually taking the time to actually implement those and then appreciate them as
soon as you're actually using them right like wow i just right clicked and selected this thing and
automatically did it this rocks um yeah like i guarantee it's it's gonna be one of those things
that every time you use that tool you're gonna be like wow this is so much easier i should have done
that like wow this is so nice that i just run this one command or just give it these three arguments
why didn't i do that earlier and i think a lot of it for me a lot of the time is do i really want to
spend that time like writing this thing like i i'll just do it i just want to follow this bug and like
again like follow the energy like ride the highs like ride the lows but also know when to spend your
time fixing a problem and like fix things that are annoying to you right it's like a squeaky door
you know you get the hinge you open you open that one door in your house and every time you open it
it squeaks and you don't realize it bothers you but now that i've said it i guarantee you're gonna
go open the door you're gonna be like that dude dude i went i'll get some oil and oil the hinge
it takes five seconds i went on a vacation uh this past weekend and the house that i went to
the stairs were silent like you walk up the stairs and nothing nothing you hear no squeaks
right whoa and i was like was it just built like no it wasn't and it was a beach property as well so
i'm like no idea how they did that but like i get back to my house and i'm like walk up the stairs i'm
here and i'm like drat you know like back on the construction combo i have a feeling i know what they
did here okay it's it's a three three-part combo nails screws and glue all three you'll know you're in
it'll never squeak but you also never get them off yeah yeah well you know at this point i'll take
them off do something to them at some point because it's driving me nuts um but okay so that's the end
of the uh staying sharp and motivated section let's move into the burnout avoidance um i think i only
have a couple little little tips here and i've kind of talked about my ideology about this a couple times
i think the number one thing that helps me avoid burnout as a full-time hacker for
nearly five years now is not putting my self-worth into uh hacking okay so if you are the kind of
person that says wow uh i think less of myself if i haven't found a bug recently or i think less of
myself if um you know i'm not ranking in the top you know whatever percent in a live hacking event um
you should really try to minimize that as much as you can i will say you might lose some competitive
uh edge if you do that but my experience has actually been the opposite when you sort of
disconnect from that you put your self-worth in something more consistent uh i'll just say intrinsic
something that is not as unstable right something that you control internally um then that will be a
lot better for your your mental health and touch grass have a hobby yeah and make children well
absolutely have sex you don't have to make children get children uh adopt children okay this
is getting out of here exactly so you know there's lots of lots of ways to do that but i think having
an intrinsic self-worth indicator is really important taking breaks like you said having hobbies doing
something outside of bug bounty because and here's the tricky thing dude because when you go full-time
bug bounty um probably what happened is your hobby just became your job um and when that happens it's
very hard to reallocate that time and mental space because and it's great because you love your job and
you're doing your job that you love every day and it's wonderful um but also you have to make space for
other things so uh make sure you're doing that intentionally if you're a full-time hunter because
it will bite you in the butt if you don't um yeah yeah the one little anecdote i'll i'll i'll leave
with and i think we we probably get close on time but um i do have a friend who he uh probably a year
or two ago he completely pivoted into a into a different job um from one thing into something
completely opposite and he did it very diligently for a year and a half or two years and then um recently
he was like you know this was a mistake actually um you know i realized that after after doing this for a
while like it's a really big grind the drawbacks where where there are drawbacks are huge and the
upsides are huge too but it's not worth it it's not giving me fulfillment and joy in the way that i
wanted it to and so he's going back he's going back to doing what he was before i would say like it's
important to um to be real with yourself about turning something that you enjoy into a job and what
that means to the relationship you have with that thing whether that's a hobby whether that's um
um a side project a part-time job bug anything like if you decide to um if you decide to turn
that into something that's going to be your source of income it's going to change the way that you
view it and when you wake up and have to do it to make money instead of waking up and getting to do
it because it's fun it's very different yeah totally agree man all right i know you got to bounce
we got a hard stop that's a wrap and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so
much for listening and if you want more critical thinking content head over to ctbb.show discord
join the discord there's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to
support the show there's the discord subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas
hack alongs exclusive scripts and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there